vous
bonsoir nouvelle semaine pour le 7-8
votre rendez vous pour faire le point
sur l'information locale en direct entre
18 et 19h sur tv fils je reçois ce soir
marie noëlle tarot bonsoir vous êtes
maire adjointe à montigny le bretonneux
chargée de l'action sociale est
également patrick moulin bonsoir vous
êtes le président de 6 l à montigny le
bretonneux
c'est de l' escalade voilà pour résumer
on va en parler dans un instant puisque
vous participez à cette 9e édition de la
semaine du handicap qui s'ouvre tout
juste sur la commune de montigny une
semaine pour changer le regard par
rapport au handicap marie noëlle tard ou
es ce que vous avez le sentiment que
cette manifestation a fait évoluer les
choses en tout cas dans votre commune je
pense que oui sinon ce serait un petit
peu désespérant mais je pense
qu'effectivement
l'objectif qui était de changer le
regard on peut pas révolutionner tout
bien entendu mais l'important c'est le
travail que l'on fait un travail de fond
auprès des élèves des écoles bien
entendu en partenariat avec l'éducation
nationale et puis avec les sportifs les
associations les parents aussi donc
c'est vrai que c'est un véritable
travail et c'est un travail qui se fait
aussi au sein de la municipalité
c'est dire que tous les services petit à
petit se trouve engagée dans cette
semaine du handicap
donc effectivement c'est véritablement
un temps où on se retrouve tous toute
l'année nous essayons au quotidien de
d'améliorer la situation des personnes
handicapé et cette semaine c'est aussi
pour montrer que ce n'est pas parce que
l'on est handicapé qu'on ne peut pas
faire de grandes choses et des choses
extraordinaires et en particulier je
pense que tout à l'heure on va en voir
l'expression instant la mobilisation de
toute la commune de toute cette commune
de montigny le bretonneux pour cette 9e
édition de la semaine du handicap on en
parle dans quelques minutes ce soir
également nous parlerons du sport la
chronique sports du lundi avec anthony
rech monsanto ni salut wilfried alors ce
soir au programme au programme et va
nous allons découvrir un une pratique
d'autodéfense peu méconnu qui vient
d'israël le krav maga et nous
reviendrons sur l'histoire du club de
plongée de saint quentin en yvelines
avec son président club qui va fêter ses
30 ans dans quelques jours et puis
évidemment les résultats du week-end du
handball du football du basket la
chronique aux sports aux alentours de
18h15 si vous nous suivez en direct à
tout à l'heure anthony avant de parler
de la semaine du handicap à montigny le
bretonneux coup d'oeil aux autres sujets
que nous allons aborder ce soir avec ses
titres en images le point sur les
programmes immobiliers de la verrière la
ville n'a pas connu de construction
depuis 40 ans et celle qu'ils vont venir
seront importantes reportage à suivre ce
week end c'était l'opération micro dons
pour soutenir des projets de solidarité
internationale nous irons devant un
supermarché de voisins-le-bretonneux
avec l'association but tiers-monde il
s'appelle françois et théo il son père
et fils s'est mordu tous les deux de bmx
vos loyers ils pratiquent leur activité
ensemble sur le terrain de
voisins-le-bretonneux et puis le
portrait de thomas houdré champion du
monde u23 de duathlon le licencié du
triathlon club de saint quentin a
remporté son titre il ya une semaine à
noter que le vice président de ce club
sera aussi avec nous sur le plateau pour
la page sports un nouveau programme
immobilier du côté de la verrière depuis
la création de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines il ya 40 ans aucune
nouvelle résidence n'avait vu le jour
pour le nouveau maire de la commune veut
changer les choses reportage de
catherine cela tôt et de brice avril
40 ans que la verrière la plus petite
commune de l'agglomération n'avait pas
connu de nouvelles constructions et
celles qui vont venir vont être
importantes à commencer par 82 logements
30 et une maison de ville et 51
logements collectifs en accession
sociale ou aider prévue fin 2013
l'opérateur accompagne les familles en
cas de difficulté mais les accompagne
aussi dans la démarche d'accession ce
qui rend possible
que cette opération bénéficie aux
verriers roi parce que évidemment ils
ont des faibles ressources un montage
qui permettra aux familles de bénéficier
d'une tva à 7% et donc d'un prix de
vente en dessous de la moyenne aux
alentours de 2850 euros le mètre carré
un premier pas dans l'aménagement de
l'écoquartier des bécanes au moins 1500
logements prévus sur des terrains de 40
hectares situé non loin de la voie
ferrée il ya plusieurs packs qui ont été
faits pour être tout à fait franc le
premier c'est la mise en place de toutes
les instances de travail et de
concertation avec l'état la région
conseil général de l'établissement
public paris saclay la communauté de
l'agglomération ça va de soi et la ville
dont on s'est réuni à plusieurs reprises
sous l'égide du sous préfet et du
président de la communauté
d'agglomération et de moi même et puis
nous travaillons maintenant un
concrètement à l'élaboration du projet
en désignant les équipes de maîtrise
d'oeuvre une opération immobilière dans
laquelle s'inscriront également des
commerces l'idée est aussi de
désenclaver les abords de la gare est de
doubler le bouchoux l'air de tous ces
sujets les verrières moi pourrons
discuter avec l'équipe municipale qui
prévoit des rencontres entre le 12 et le
25 novembre
premier invité du 7-8 de ce 8 octobre
pour évoquer la semaine du handicap qui
s'ouvre du côté de montigny le
bretonneux marie noëlle tao c'est un
rendez vous nous disiez en début
d'émission qui fédère toute la ville
tous les secteurs d'activités de la
ville sont présents et déjà pendant la
semaine c'est surtout les enfants qui
vont être concernés vous allez les voir
il y aura des animations également avec
les classes de la ville comment ça va se
dérouler cette sensibilisation au
handicap pour les plus jeunes alors la
sensibilisation pour les plus jeunes
c'est effectivement les classes qui vont
venir nous retrouver au gymnase pierre
de coubertin où il y aura un certain
nombre d'activités c'est à dire que nous
mettrons les enfants en situation de
handicap que ce soit handicap moteur ou
handicap sensoriel il y aura des
ateliers braille et il y aura des jeux
sous forme torball cécifoot en haut
fauteuils etc donc ce sont des activités
tout au long de la semaine où les
différentes classes en fonction des
niveaux bien entendu on ne va pas faire
les mêmes choses que ce soit pour des
cm2 ou pour des cp mais effectivement
nous allons leur permettre de découvrir
ce que c'est que d'être handicapé et de
ce que l'on peut faire même si l'on ne
se trouve en fauteuil ou si on ne voit
pas et là c'est la neuvième édition
seront des prix sur la ville donc il ya
déjà eu des sensibilisations pour les
plus jeunes ils réagissent comme en
général alors jeté un jeu pour eux un
petit peu au début et puis après se
rendre compte que c'est quand même plus
sérieux que ça disait le débit sans
conscience et alors tout d'abord il ya
quelque chose d'extraordinaire avec les
enfants c'est que ils ont pas de
retenues pour poser les questions donc
lorsqu'il rencontre des personnes en
situation de handicap et bien ils vont
poser les questions naturellement sans
aucune gêne et c'est ça aussi qui est
important c'est qu'il ya un dialogue qui
c'est qui s'instaure entre les enfants
et puis les personnes et les enfants en
prennent vraiment conscience et j'ai
envie de dire l'année dernière nous
avons fait 1 le mercredi avec les
centres de loisirs les enfants se sont
promenés dans la ville en situation de
handicap ou en fauteuil et tous et
plusieurs enfants m'ont dit ce qui est
très dur c'est le regard des gens est
donc quelque part notre idée de changer
le regard c'est tout à fait ça et c'est
ce que je leur ai dit alors c'est
peut-être un petit peu utopiste mais
peut-être que quand eux seront adultes
et bien ils n'auront plus regard ils
trouveront ça tout à fait naturel et on
croisera les personnes en soins de ce
même besoin la civilisation le regard
arrachant le regard aura changé les
audois c'est toujours travailler quand
même c'est toujours bien de vivre
rappeler et intervenir au-delà de cette
semaine comment la ville intervient
aussi en en matière de handicap parce qu
il ya une semaine donc c'est très bien
mais au-delà de cette semaine alors bien
entendu la semaine c'est l'élément phare
du travail que l'on fait le quotidien on
travaille avec les services techniques
en particulier sur tout ce qui est
accessibilité sur les voiries sur le
bâtiment il ya eu un travail très
importante qui a été fait pour la voirie
avec la communauté d'agglomération
justement pour voir l'accessibilité au
niveau de la voirie et il y a eu
également un travail qui a été fait par
les services techniques de la mairie
pour tout ce qui est patrimoine bâti de
façon à rendre accessible à tous et bien
effectivement tous les bâtiments publics
de la ville donc ça c'est ce travail là
qui a été fait il a été fait également
aussi on est en train de réfléchir à
d'autres moyens parce que être handicapé
ce n'est pas être exclue de la cité
c'est au contraire être un citoyen comme
les autres et pouvoir participer et donc
il y a un certain nombre d'actions qui
sont développés tout au long de l'année
bien souvent avec des bénévoles en
particulier avec l'association valentin
haüy nous faisons le montigny audio
c'est à dire que nous lisons le journal
de montigny et nous le nous le
transmettons gratuitement aux personnes
en situation de difficultés pour lire
aussi bien les personnes handicapées est
la même les personnes âgées peuvent en
bénéficier
et puis nous venons de voter au dernier
conseil municipal les souffleurs d'image
c'est à dire que ce sont des jeunes qui
sont en formation théâtrale qui peuvent
accompagner une personne non voyante
dans sur pour aller voir une pièce de
théâtre et où il explique ce qu'il voit
il n'interprète pas ils disent il dit
que j'associe à ce qu'il intervient pour
ça alors ça alors ça a été fait avec
l'école de théâtre au clair de la lune
avec l'école de théâtre de montigny et
donc on est en train de travailler sur
ce projet là et ça a été votée au
dernier conseil municipal donc ça se met
en place et des personnes voilà besoin
de ce service là elles peuvent se
rapprocher du service culturel donc il y
à tout ce travail là et puis il ya aussi
tout l'accompagnement que nous mettons
en place avec tout le service de
maintien à domicile que ce soit les
aides ménagères le portage de repas la
téléassistance nicolas et sa boîte à
outils donc ce sont toutes les actions
que nous faisons pour permettre aux
personnes handicapées de pouvoir vivre
le mieux possible dans la ville et de
tout cela forcément que vous allez en
parler pendant la semaine du handicap si
ce sera c'est tout au long de la semaine
mais ce sera principalement pour le
public durant le week end le temps fort
c'est principalement durant le week end
avec une mobilisation vous voulez
repréciser bruyamment fort il y en aura
d'autres moments forts par exemple
demain nous avons spécial olympiques ce
qui est une course inter entreprises et
qui a vraiment un succès de plus en plus
nous espérons avoir au moins une
quarantaine d'équipés représentant
différentes entreprises et qui
permettent à des enfants en situation de
handicap de participer il y en a qui
sont allés aux jeux paralympiques donc
ça c'est important et ça c'est des dieux
aux personnes qui sont salariés des
entreprises voilà voilà mon club mais
pour l'europe et pour le grand public
c'est les personnes salariées
l'entreprise et qui font une action les
entreprises participant financièrement
pour engager les équipes nous avons
également nous sommes aussi dans l'année
sur national de l'autisme et nous avons
mis un petit peu un focus aussi sur sur
ces journées là sur ces actions là donc
je dis nous aurons
spectacle qui s'appelle le bal des
pompiers ça a été réalisé par un papa
dont l'enfant est né le jour du bal des
pompiers c'est pour ça qu'il l'a appelé
comme ça un spectacle avec beaucoup
d'humour et beaucoup de tendresse sur
l'autisme et nous aurons également une
conférence vendredi sur l'autisme
programme très complet à retrouver sur
notre site internet et j'en viens au
week end pour donner la parole à patrick
- tout même qui est venu sur ce plateau
vous êtes le président de l'association
du club iny montain d'escaladé libre le
ciel très joli nom et vous allez
participer vous allez permettre de
grimper en situation de handicap c'est
bien ça c'est ça alors il ne dimanche
après-midi a pas de notre 14h et 17h
nous installons sur le mur de
du gymnase pierre de coubertin à
montigny un ensemble de cordes et puis
nous accueillons les personnes
handicapées ou invalides et nous
encadrons les personnes pour que quel
que soit leur handicap
la mal voyance ou
problèmes d'application de pouvoir
monter sur sur le mur avec avec toute la
sécurité qui va bien et les personnes
qui y viennent me voir avec
peut-être la chance de être valide et
bien nous leur proposons de de voir ce
que ce qu'est la situation de handicap
donc soit en bande dans les yeux pour
grimper dans une situation de non
voyance ou bien
d'attacher un des membres pouvoir ce que
ça donne quand on n'a pas les quatre
membres il nous est arrivé sur ce rendez
vous sur cette semaine eh bien ça a
commencé il ya longtemps il ya sept ans
maintenant puisque c'est la neuvième
édition de cette semaine à montigny et
le club ciel n'y participe depuis
s'étant donc ce sera la septième
participation est déjà une section de
personnes en situation de handicap au
sein du club non nous n'avons pas de
section particulière sur tout le monde
peut faire mais on ne peut venir au club
alors évidemment il ya la difficulté de
l'autonomie mais
dès lors qu' on ne peut assurer qu'ils
aient autonomie on peut assurer
quelqu'un dans l' escalade c'est quelque
chose qui se développe beaucoup jeu
cette année il ya eu les championnats du
monde d'escaladé bercy et il ya eu une
une période une partie escalade qui a
été vraiment été très mouvementée
beaucoup de gens alors j'ai entendu que
ce week-end il y aurait l'équipe de
france d'escaladé alors exemple alors à
ce propos
lors des championnats du monde à bercy
nous avons un nouveau champion du monde
en 10 capes en handi grimpe et cette
personne sera étaient là l'année
dernière nous a montré comment elle a
grimpé et je pense qu'elle a donné
beaucoup d'une grande leçon m'a beaucoup
sur à la fois le courage et puis aussi
les techniques d'escaladé parce que
c'est des gens qui craint pas vraiment
très très fort et nous aurons philippe
brière qui viendra avec l'équipe de
france et puis cette personne qui est
maintenant
champion du monde et ce sera donc ce
week end semaine du handicap du côté de
montigny le bretonneux pour finir cette
séquence une semaine du handicap est ce
utile nous vous avons posé la question
dans les rues de montigny-le-bretonneux
je pense être utile dans la mesure où ça
va sensibiliser
les gens sur la problématique de
l'handicap comme toutes les campagnes
aussi bien contre le cancer contre enfin
informer les gens du de certains fléaux
de la société c'est toujours utile oui
oui tout à fait très très importante
mais pour que les gens sachent et gens
participent aussi à ce que peut être la
difficulté d'autres parents ayant un
enfant handicapé et pour que le handicap
soit pris en compte mais tous les
handicaps faut pas oublier le handicap
psychique dont on se garde bien de
parler parce qu'ils posent d'autres
questions et parce que les structures
d'accueil n'existe guère
ça ça a toujours été oubliée voilà c'est
pour des dons oui ça peut ça peut aider
pour avancer dans les recherches de
l'handicapé faire évoluer de ce qu'on a
besoin oui oui tout à fait c'est très
utile parce que ça permet aussi aux gens
de bain gens qui sont pas trop
au courant de ce de se pencher un petit
peu plus sur la question et même de
participer à des activités ou des choses
comme ça
et l'opération séduit vous êtes rassurés
rassurer et puis je voulais aussi dire
que nous avons un temps fort que
j'allais oublier je voudrais pas
l'oublier il est très important surtout
pour les personnes handicapées nous
faisons le handicafé
moment au cours duquel les perses les
entreprises et les personnes handicapées
qui cherchent un emploi peuvent se
rencontrer ce sera jeudi voilà à
l'espace 50 ans à montigny le bretonneux
d'être venu sur le plateau celle du
handicap jusqu'au 14 octobre programme
complet sur votre site anthony rech va
me rejoindre pour la page de sport
auparavant nous revenons sur l'opération
microdon une opération pour soutenir des
projets de solidarité internationale
exemple devant ce supermarché de
voisins-le-bretonneux avec l'association
bucs tiers-monde
un simple bip en caisse pour faire un
don de 2 euros ou plus c'est la
quatrième année consécutive de
l'opération microdon dans les
supermarchés des yvelines comme ici à
voisins le bretonneux des associations
de la coopération internationale peuvent
ainsi récolter des fonds pour alimenter
leurs projets dans les pays en voie de
développement donner des petites sommes
un nouveau modèle de générosité on pense
que c'est un changement d'usagé qui
évoluent avec les générations les
générations des seniors plus ont un mode
de réponse à la sollicitation au don qui
est traditionnellement coupons papier un
chèque et on pense que ce mode de don va
laisser place petit à petit à des
générosités dit générosité quotidienne
avec des actes de dons dans la vie de
tous les jours
les associations sont choisis par le
département exemple avec but tiers monde
qui oeuvre pour l'éducation au burkina
faso 270 adhérents et 35 ans d'action
comme avec ce lycée construit en 2005
dans une zone rurale du burkina à la
frontière du togo à la rentrée 2012 il y
à 1000 élèves
qui rentrent donc au lycée de view et
parmi ces mille élèves il y a deux cents
enfants qui sont pris en charge par les
adhérents de buxy au monde 200 enfants
dont on paie la scolarité la nourriture
est tous là de la sixième à la terminale
l'année dernière nous avons récolté
quasiment 3000 euros 3000 euros c'est
pas tout à fait la moitié c'est à peu
près quatre mois de nourriture pour les
enfants donc c'est très important cette
année 18 associations posté dans 23
points de vente ont pu bénéficier de
cette organisation chaque opération leur
permet de récolter entre 700 et 2000
euros près de 120 manifestations ont été
organisées en france depuis la création
de micro dons en 2007